One of the things I find fascinating
about Elon Musk is how he uses language
differently from what you would
typically consider a good speaker. He's
not polished.
>> it's it's sort of quite quite fun to do
that.
>> His answers are full of filler words.
>> Um and um
you know, um
>> And his explanations often go on dense
and technical rabbit trails.
>> They're designed to work with a
biological neural net, our brains.
>> So the big question is, why do Elon
Musk's words regularly go viral and move
markets when his speaking technique
appears to be so terrible? What does he
know
that good speakers don't? After watching
dozens of hours of Elon speaking, I've
discovered four things he does
incredibly well that make him so
compelling. And each of these pieces
confirm what we've noticed from coaching
thousands of leaders, managers, and CEOs
to speak better over the past 8 years.
These four ideas are so powerful, they
may have made Elon more than just the
richest man on the planet, but actually,
in my opinion, one of the most genius
communicators alive. So let's break it
down, starting with the first mystery,
how Elon gets away with rambling
responses.
>> Why do you like the letter X as much as
you do?
>> Well,
I mean, yeah, it's good question,
honestly.
>> Watch how Elon almost gets lost in a
ramble and then uses a technique to
bring himself back home. See if you can
spot it.
>> So, um
I mean, it started off with where I
think it's a way back
ancient times in '99.
It's a
a long-winded way of saying
that it's uh I'm I'm just kind of slowly
building
revisiting this idea that I had 25 years
ago
to create a more efficient
um
money database.
>> Did you catch it? Elon went rambling
about X payments, information theory,
and then suddenly he realizes that he's
been rambling for too long and he snaps
back with six words.
>> So anyway, so it's so this long-winded
way of saying
>> and he's back on track. This technique
is called a summary prompt. A summary
prompt is a technique that signals to
you and your audience that you're about
to deliver your main message. And Elon
uses this all the time.
>> So basically real-world AI. But it
basically tends to serve the serve the
least served. So basically what you have
to have is
>> Notice the pattern? In these examples,
Elon's reset button is the word
basically. It prompts him to get back on
track, to reconnect with the main
message. What studies show is that all
speaking starts in a pre-verbal state in
your subconscious. And when you're
speaking, your subconscious is just
delivering the auto-completion of your
sentences. And when you use something
like a summary prompt, you're hijacking
that process and you're directing it to
give you exactly what you need. And it's
beautiful because you can use this to
get rid of all of the rambling so that
people don't remember that and just
remember you landing strong with a
summarizing point.
>> Bottom line is I think
>> But at the end of the day
>> Well, I think ultimately the fundamental
value of the net effect
>> effect is
>> So the most important the toughest
remaining problem is a
>> What matters is that it is solved.
>> What matters is that it is it is
achieved.
>> That's what really matters. Make you
more than you take.
>> By the way, these are just a few
examples of the summary prompts that
Elon uses. So we put together this bonus
package where we have a list of all of
the summary prompts we found him using
and video of me going over each one, why
I think he's using those in those
moment, how I would apply them. So
you're welcome to use those if you're
interested. But now that you know how
Elon summarizes his point so that his
conclusions go viral instead of his
rambles, you're ready to understand the
second piece of Elon's speaking formula.
Because
rambling isn't Elon's only bad speaking
issue.
I want you to take a look at this clip
where Elon explains the concept of his
Neuralink product.
>> One of the things that would
be good for ensuring that
the future is one that we want is to
more tightly couple
human world to digital intelligence. But
what is it that
inhibits human machine symbiosis? It's
the data rate. The way to think of the
Neuralink device is kind of like a
a Fitbit or an Apple Watch but but with
with tiny tiny wires very very tiny
wires tied to wires so tiny it's hard to
even see them.
>> The actual topic Elon was talking about
just now is literally neuroscience, but
suddenly it's not.
It's a Fitbit for your brain.
How does he do that?
>> The way to think of the Neuralink device
is kind of like a
a Fitbit or an Apple Watch.
>> The way to think of this is
That's another prompt.
But it's not summarizing. This time it's
introducing a new idea. It's providing
clarity. Look at Elon in action.
>> So, one way to think of this is to say I
mean a way to think of it is that I
guess the rough way to think about it is
>> Yeah, one way to look at technology is
to
>> Imagine you're very confident that we
were going to be visited by
super intelligent aliens.
>> The real trick of it is
>> Here's the thing to understand about
like the way I view it is
>> a tiny candle
in a vast darkness.
>> In each of these examples, Elon isn't
just signaling here's my main point.
What he's doing is he's translating his
ideas by taking something that the
audience doesn't understand and he's
using analogies, mental models, or other
illustrations to transforming into
something that they do. In other times,
he's using clarity prompts to clarify
his own perspective to make sure that
he's not misunderstood.
>> So, what I mean by that is Now, I I
should characterize what I mean by I
mean the the point I want to be clear is
I don't want to be clear that these
>> Basically, anytime Elon senses a gap in
understanding between what he says and
what the other person hears, he stops
and closes that gap with a clarity
prompt. And the word senses here is very
important. This is not a science, it's
an art.
You will sense this as well as you're
speaking. And when you sense that you're
not being understood, you can just reach
for a prompt just like Elon does. I want
to be clear or to be clear what I mean.
And watch your brain just fill in a way
to clarify your thinking. So, now we
have two pieces of Elon's formula.
But Elon is notorious for a third
speaking issue. And here's how piece
three of the toolkit addresses that.
>> take it that it's inevitable at this
point that some version of AI is coming
down the line.
How do we How do we steer through that?
>> Well, I'm not normally an advocate of
regulation and oversight. This is a case
where you have a very serious danger to
the public. I think the danger of AI is
much greater than the the the danger of
nuclear warheads. By a lot. Mark my
words.
AI is far more dangerous than nukes.
Far. So, why do we have no regulatory
oversight?
>> If you followed Elon at all, you know
that he is no stranger to bold
predictions. Whether it's cars that can
drive themselves with zero human
interaction, self-sustaining Mars
colonies by 2050, or being able to
travel between LA and SF in 30 minutes.
So, how is it that even when those
claims sometimes seem ridiculous or
haven't even come true in the past, Elon
still inspires such belief in his
listeners? It's not just his track
record. It's actually the way he sets up
his sentences to inspire conviction.
So, listen again.
>> That that would be insane. And mark my
words,
AI is far more dangerous than nukes.
Far.
>> Mark my words.
This is our third prompt type.
We call it the conviction prompt.
Even if you weren't sure what you were
going to say when you began, which is
the whole point of these prompts, your
prompt forces your brain into a state of
absolute certainty.
Here are some of Elon's most used
conviction prompts.
>> I'm confident that then I'm confident
that you can do I I am confident that
Like I'm confident by 2030. We're very
confident that can't emphasize it
enough. I I like really can't emphasize
this enough. And it's very important to
emphasize that One thing that we can be
quite certain of there's no question in
my mind.
>> There's different flavors here. I'm
confident that I can't emphasize enough.
No question in my mind. Mark my words.
But all these prompts, they open a loop
of conviction. Conviction that what's
about to be said is something that the
speaker believes in deeply, and that you
should pay attention. However,
there's something even more interesting
that Elon does.
>> I mean, so cautiously optimistic we'll
be able to see faster than a
the world's fastest bullet train even in
in a 0.8 mile stretch. But I I I think
it is accurate to say that if
successful, Optimus will be the biggest
product ever. I'm actually fairly
confident it will be able to do that
route. I think it will turn out to be
true. Safe to say that
>> Elon does this all the time.
Instead of just hype, he sounds like
someone who's being careful, measured,
scientific. Most of us think expressing
conviction means being louder or more
emphatic. But in many cases, it's just a
matter of prompting yourself with the
right words. Sometimes that's forceful.
I can't emphasize this enough. There's
no question on my mind. And other times,
it's understated. It's safe to say that
I think it'll turn out to be true that
So, if you feel like your audience is
skeptical or that you're making a point
that is counterintuitive and goes
against common wisdom, you can prompt
your brain using any of these phrases.
And a statement of conviction will
automatically follow. Once Elon
eliminates rambling, confusion, and
doubt, we're left with one final
mystery. Many speakers use prompts like
these, from Barack Obama to Brené Brown.
But it turns out that the final piece
that makes Elon sound so different than
your your average good speaker
isn't just the words that he says.
It's the root of Elon's good speaking
that traditional speaking coaches almost
completely ignore.
And once you understand it, it unlocks
Elon's entire formula. To see what I'm
talking about, watch this viral clip of
what happened when Elon gets asked a
question about whether his tweets hurt
his companies.
>> Do your tweets hurt the company? Are
there Tesla owners who say, "I don't
agree with his political position
because and I know it because he shares
so much of it." Or there advertisers on
Twitter that Linda Yaccarino will come
and say, "You got to stop, man. We're
you know, I can't get these ads because
of some of the things you tweet."
>> You know, I'm reminded of
uh
the
it was a scene in The Princess Bride.
Great movie, where
he confronts the person who killed his
father.
And he says,
"Offer me money.
Offer me power.
I don't care.
>> So, you just don't care.
>> I'll say what I want to say, and if if
if uh
if the consequence of that is losing
money, so be it.
>> The reason Elon's speaking feels so
real, even when he's using prompts to
direct his speaking, is because
they're not planned.
Elon is willing to do something that
terrifies most speakers.
He thinks out loud.
He lets himself sound uncertain. He
pauses. He fumbles.
And he doesn't care. So, when we train
CEOs, we call this spontaneous speaking.
It's the meta skill of trusting your
brain to deliver the right words, even
when you don't know what they are yet.
When Elon responds here, he has 12 full
seconds of silence on camera. That's an
eternity. It's multiple lifetimes in
media time. Most speakers would panic,
and most speaking coaches
will tell you to fill the space. Say
something, anything.
Instead, Elon is willing to sit with
what he's feeling
until his brain serves up what he needs.
So, here's Elon Musk's meta pattern, and
the ultimate meta skill to adopt,
especially if you're not a traditional
good speaker. First of all, Elon thinks
deeply about topics that he cares about.
He does the deep work in that area. And
when he answers a question, he isn't
afraid to think out loud, at the cost of
rambling a bit, and sometimes coming
close to losing his way. But when he
notices that happening, all he does is
he prompts his brain for summaries, for
clarity or conviction, whichever's
needed in the moment. And thanks to the
thinking that he's done previously, his
subconscious brain naturally serves him
what he needs. And that creates answers
that people remember and that people
share. Every single viral Elon clip
follows this pattern. This is what we've
discovered working with thousands of
people who want to improve their
speaking. You don't need to know where
you're going when you start speaking.
You just need to trust that your brain
will get you there. When you let go of
the need to sound perfect, magic
happens. You don't need to be a
billionaire. You don't need to run five
companies. You don't need to be building
rockets.
You just need to
internalize your ideas,
speak before you overthink, before you
know what you're going to say,
use prompts to nudge your brain to
deliver what you need when you need it,
and have the courage to be imperfect and
unpolished along the way.
We have a full list of all of Elon's
prompts from this video, plus a bunch
more that we didn't get to in the link
below. If you'd like to learn a totally
different way of using prompts from
someone who's considered a traditionally
good speaker, watch this video next
breaking down President Obama's most
effective speaking moves.